se prevé que sea incluso más alta a la
que ella fue en el 2018 cuando la
participación fue del
45% para entender bien estos porcentajes
de participación hay que ver que hoy son
las elecciones abiertas a la mayoría de
la población al 25 millones de iraquíes
que están habilitados para votar pero
dos días atrás fueron elecciones para
los militares para los desplazados y
para muchísimos funcionarios y en ese
escenario ya la participación sube por
encima del 70% así que tendremos una
participación más o menos similar a la
del 2018 que fue 45 por ciento lo que es
realmente un fracaso para las
instituciones políticas iraquíes que
habían respondido a ese llamado de esa
población en el 2019 de adelantar estas
elecciones y además de reformar esa ley
electoral trayendo por ejemplo creando
nuevos distritos electorales que
permitieran que esos candidatos no
llegaran a hacer candidatos por los
partidos políticos y no de manera
independiente con una intención de que
la gente participara muchísimo más y
sintiera mayor compromiso con esto pero
no fue así especialmente en la población
joven en la que no ha votado porque ve
que no hay respuesta hacia ellos no
confían en la gracia política en la
corrupción en la falta de trabajo no hay
servicios públicos y la pobreza se ha
hecho mayor como consecuencia también de
la pandemia así que vamos a esperar como
ya se prevé una participación muy baja y
vamos a ver cuál va a ser la respuesta
de los políticos iraquíes